all right Ted see in a few minutes well
Street artists and vendors or something
we see often across Las Vegas especially
on Fremont Street now in the city
performers have to register for a permit
and they need to stay in designated
areas but as many see more people
setting up shop in the strips selling
art even homemade music videos they're
wondering what the rules are in Clark
County Sasha Loftus with more
cluttered Street vendors lining Las
Vegas Boulevard
specifically in front of the Bellagio
Selling paintings tarot readings and
these homemade music videos I think it's
better to kind of have it in one area
and not just spread out it all seems
similar to what we see on Fremont Street
and some like Rahi odlani say they've
moved their stations here the different
energy The Fountain and music
for more room and fewer regulations
mainly to avoid Busker permits and
placements in the city every two hours
we need to change the circle and
sometimes most of the time we cannot
find the circulars so what are the
County's rules on this
we reached out to the Clark County
business license and they said it's
quote unlawful for business to be
conducted in the public right-of-way in
this case along the sidewalk on Las
Vegas Boulevard but metro police
officers we spoke with say because
vendors like this are working as artists
and not selling food or drinks they're
allowed to stay atlani calls it a great
opportunity to reach a new audience
While others walking through wish
something would change I think if we're
going to have it it needs to be kind of
centrally located Sasha Loftus 8 News
Now